hey guys I'm Ryan Wright and I'm Katie
du Bois Katie and I are gonna be
watching a trailer that every single
human being that I've ever interacted
with has been asking me to watch called
DC's legends of tomorrow the first look
I believe this is a CW show and if I'm
not mistaken legends of tomorrow is
actually about many of the gods from
like you know weirdness a lot like like
Shiva come on Zeus okay coming together
uh-huh and they so different origins of
gods come here they come they come
together but that's what it is they come
together they come together so the
Buckeye is there ha ha ha no I have no
idea what the [ __ ] this is I am NOT a
comic book nerd like most of you that's
what I do
Lila nori
I started this alone and had every
intention of keeping it that way had a
plan life had a different one
and then things just got stranger
are they bringing them all together
partners burners but the hard
inescapable truth is that sometimes
we're not enough sometimes the world
needs a team you call this a team
a girl with wings in the past lives
complex a deceased assassin
a pair of criminals
and a billionaire was more tech than he
clearly knows what to do with I know
exactly what to do with it
most of the time and I'm a half a hero
and my other half is combustible
what you're up against is bigger than
all of us which is why it's gonna take
all of you
his name is Vandal Savage he's been
alive thousands of years he is
morale and commands the most powerful
army the world has ever seen
and what makes you think we could stop
him because one day you do rip hunter
I'm from East London oh and the future
I'm a member of the time masters an
organization charged with protecting
history itself
and in the future as unlikely as it may
seem
you people become a team
well those of you who survived it be
savages evil spans the course of history
so we will have to travel through time
to stop it
hey I don't know who these people are
Michelle's gonna [ __ ] rock can throw
to us we got this thing nailed down why
did you say that
I can't imagine any kind of future where
I am a hero well you know in the future
none of you are heroes your legend
so you weren't dead nope
you were just small you don't believe me
all right just watch so tiny wait what
is this is a movie a part is it a show
because that would be pretty sweet if it
was a show that we're you know have
arrow going and they have flash going
but then they have this other one going
that's iron man no oh okay you have just
made us look so bad in front of the
camera just don't you know what fanboys
are like if we get anything wrong we
really an hour-long video and get like
99% of the information right but if we
get one percent wrong we get [ __ ]
crucified it's not the first time I've
been wrong I don't watch the flash and I
don't watch Harrow it's one of those
shows where people are always saying how
have you not seen this have you not seen
this and then I started watching one of
those happy probably not seeing this
show and then everyone's still like well
what about this other show what about
this other show so one of those in that
little conundrum is the flash and arrow
but this right here watching this
trailer line I was like I cannot miss
out on this I am going to watch all the
episodes of both of those shows now I
feel like I've been spoiled is the first
like comic book - television adaptation
that I've been watching as a late is
daredevil and that's like ah it's on
Netflix it's raw its gritty and so when
I hear about like a CW show I get this
like ego up about like that smooth
censored and stuff but I everyone says
they're like [ __ ] amazing though so I
do want to check it out
watching this I was like yeah it doesn't
need to be like some super violent [ __ ]
no it doesn't have to be dark and gritty
it can be a little bit more just like
fun
to be a pg-13 yeah
you know so I do want to check this out
I want to get caught or know these
[ __ ] people are I'm gonna totally
look up each character on Wikipedia yeah
I been on YouTube the history of this
character and then BAM I'm gonna act
like I know [ __ ] now all these guys know
what like also is in there a little bit
is um Doctor Who
weirdly I get like this dark from the
British guy who's like I come from the
future and I know all the things and I'm
handsome
slimming British and I know that's not
obviously the Doctor Who character but I
think they're feeding into that audience
which is obviously so big something
about this team that's been assembled
kind of seems to me like not for all of
them but just like a couple of them kind
of feels like yeah we should bring in
this guy because he's like the DC
version of this Marvel character I mean
first one comes to mind is the atom is
like he's pretty much doing stuck Wow
they're portraying him here I don't know
the atom so maybe he's totally different
but from what they're portraying him as
in this trailer I was like a lot people
are gonna think that's Iron Man at first
well you have to you have to find a
character that you relate to right yeah
if you're if you feel like you're an
awesome like engineer and you could like
build something that's that character
for you if you feel like you're good at
fighting that's a character if you feel
like you're good like outwitting there
are special characters for each kind of
avenue that you could relate to
there's gotta be character that's like
really good at masturbating though like
that should be his or her specialty cuz
I can really relate why'd you what would
your name be like that big the pump the
pumper Peter Martin the mega Bader the
mega Peter there you go mega Peter yo yo
huh your son of a [ __ ] show I thought
it was really fun that he became tiny at
the end yeah that to me was a good
button to end on I was like yeah he's
tiny and my girlfriend says the same
exact thing about me like we never get
to the finish line and then she laughs
and goes funny how you became tiny at
the end
we're going to therapy for it braiding
time I will definitely be watching
legends of tomorrow as well as watching
the flash and arrow
finally and I'm yeah I really I think
I'll check it out too you don't get a
screen shot anyway guys if you're new to
the channel you can subscribe to the
real rejects you can check out kzoo boss
channel where it's Katie and her channel
and you can follow us on Facebook
Instagram and Twitter where if we get
enough followers product placement
um no beanies these are great because
they do many things for you that make
life better they can keep your head warm
and they can keep your balls warm
everyone should know this everyone it
doesn't do anything for a woman really
just make some looking weird and put our
like tiny dog in it or something can
select a tiny dog basket yeah like as if
you're strong enough to carry a tiny dog
women are weak wish I had a tiny dog I
didn't feel hurt at all are you crying
crying you're crying you mustn't expose
my powers
you mustn't expose my limits